je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du
meilleur smartphone de gaming du moment
c'est le rockfon 7 alors vous connaissez
probablement rockfun je vous en ai
énormément déjà parlé les autres années
chaque année asus sort son rockfold
nouvelle version améliorée corrigée avec
plein de super fonctionnalités et ce qui
donne aujourd'hui le meilleur tout
simplement même s'il est d'ailleurs loin
d'être parfait pas forcément complet
surtout mais sur l'expérience gaming et
vous allez voir bien plus que gaming et
bien le rock V est une petite bombe on y
va
[Musique]
alors on va commencer tout est dans
cette boîte en tout cas c'est le
packaging média qui m'a envoyé je sais
pas si c'est celui-là que vous allez
avoir il y a une expérience qui est
vraiment particulière et on ne peut pas
parler du rockfone 7 sans venir vous
montrer l'expérience multimédia alors
avant de vous montrer le smartphone plus
en détail qui ressemble quand même
plutôt pas mal au rock fan 6 et sans
parler également de son accessoire
principal que je vous recommande avec
d'ailleurs des précommandes qui sont
intéressants jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'avril il vous offre l'aéro actif
couleur qui permet franchement de
descendre la température de le refroidir
ça l'euro c'est un peu plus fat mais
pour autant il est intéressant en terme
d'expérience de jeu parce que vous avez
différents boutons à l'arrière pour
venir augmenter votre expérience de jeu
et on sent vraiment que ça vient
refroidir on sent que ça ventile donc ça
c'est plutôt cool d'ailleurs si ce
smartphone vous intéresse je vous mets
un lien d'affiliation dans la
description les jeter un petit coup
d'oeil et puis il y a surtout cette
boîte qui est absolument monumentale
alors on va commencer par le
commencement lorsque vous unboxer votre
smartphone lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous
allez avoir une expérience qui va sortir
et qui va se faire ici on vous donne une
mission secrète bon par contre vous le
voyez le smartphone c'est un petit
miroir on se voit vraiment à travers
donc vous êtes dans un cockpit et on
vous donne votre mission ici vous
recevez un message qui vous explique ce
qui va se passer on vous demande ensuite
retirer la coque pour maximiser
l'expérience parce que fatalement on va
venir le positionner là-dedans ensuite
on vous demande de venir utiliser cette
partie que vous avez sur l'emballage
vous venez vous poser le smartphone
dedans hop là qui vient très très bien
se positionner continu et ensuite il est
connecté on vous explique ensuite il
faut venir lancer Unchained STAPS un
vrai bouton avec un clic ça c'est quand
même vachement bien foutu donc là ça
démarre votre véhicule là maintenant il
faut choisir la destination donc vous
avez le bouton destination qui a un vrai
bouton avec un vrai clique écouter donc
là vous partez à destination la
destination et checker et ensuite vous
appuyez sur tes coffres pour décoller et
là c'est parti mon Tintin donc là tout
se met en branle et vous allez partir
avec votre vaisseau dans l'espace on
vous demande de prendre le smartphone et
le sortir et maintenant on va pouvoir
venir pivoter comme ça directement OK et
on nous explique on va pouvoir utiliser
les hatr trigger pour me dire shooter
les obstacles très facilement voilà je
le mets en face j'utilise un trigger et
je tire avec comme ça j'élimine tout ce
qui m'arrive en face il y a maintenant
il m'explique il va falloir venir
pivoter pour venir pivoter j'appuie sur
l'air trigger façon alterner comme ça
maintenant il faut que je retourne mon
smartphone je viens scanner bon pour de
faux bien évidemment bien scanner je
choisis un personnage ensuite vous créez
votre personnage et ensuite vous
retrouver dans l'expérience Asus donc il
y a une première expérience de gaming
d'Elon boxing et je trouve ça vachement
bien parce que ça vous emmène vraiment
dans un autre monde alors une fois que
vous avez ouvert et que vous avez ça et
bien vous allez le garder parce que
globalement vous allez pas en faire
grand chose mais je trouve que l'idée
elle est vraiment là et une fois de plus
on vous emmène dans un univers qui est
très particulier que je trouve vraiment
super bien alors la boîte que j'ai ici
on est sur l'espèce de carton j'ai
l'impression ici donc là hop on vient
ouvrir donc là on a les petites docks et
compagnie le smartphone et normalement
si tu veux juste ici mais vous vous en
douter très bien moi je l'ai enlevé et
après quand vous finissez d'enlever ça
et bien on va arriver avec l'irok kif
kooler qui va être situé juste là
dessous alors là il y aura qui couleur
il est en option mais si vous achetez
l'Ultimate et je vous expliquerai tout à
l'heure et bien vous l'avez avec on va
avoir également une petite housse pour
venir ranger son aéro actif couleur et
bien à l'intérieur ici ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal fichu vous avez
ensuite votre bloc de charge qui est
inclus qui est juste ici rock donc ça
c'est plutôt cool également et votre
câble de chargement voilà comme ça c'est
efficace vous avez ce qu'il faut cette
boîte vient se recycler bien vu bien
penser on est dans l'air du temps bravo
Asus et voilà pour cette expérience que
je trouve juste très sympa au niveau de
l'unboxing alors je vous le dis je ne
sais pas si c'est un packaging que vous
vous
bon il va y avoir des mouvements vous
allez appuyer il y a des mouvements
glissés il y a différents mouvements qui
sont très sympas qui vous permettent
totalement de venir maximiser votre
expérience et la personnaliser
totalement en jouant donc ça c'est bien
on va retrouver sur le dessous une prise
jack ça c'est aussi le point fort de ce
smartphone c'est que Asus ça fait le
choix de conserver cette prise jack pour
vous puissiez totalement maximiser votre
expérience en plus ici vous avez le
direct virtuo pour casque donc une
superbe expérience audio au casque vous
le recharger ici en USB c comme vous
allez pouvoir venir brancher votre iron
actif couleur si vous le prenez si vous
l'achetez ou du moins si vous l'avez
lors de l'offre de lancement et bien il
vient se positionner juste ici alors
regardez vous avez les deux petites
pines ici là plus la prise usb-c et
après en dessous vous allez pouvoir
retrouver de l'USB C pour le recharger
également ici et une prise jack pour
bien vous brancher votre tiroir de carte
SIM qui se situe là et qui est une fois
de plus dans l'univers et bien décoré et
sur le dessus il y a pas grand chose
autre élément de design qui est hyper
important ici c'est l'écran que vous
allez avoir à l'arrière c'est à dire
l'écran rock vision alors cet écran rock
vision n'est pas réellement un écran ça
va dépendre de la version que vous allez
prendre parce que si vous allez sur le
rockfon 7 c'est plus des pixels que vous
allez avoir tandis que si vous arrivez
sur le modèle ultimate ça va pour le
coup réellement être un écran l'écran
une grande vision ça va être de
l'oreille en fait vous venez ici dans
Armory Cry pour venir le paramétrer et
dans Armory Cry vous allez avoir plein
d'options différentes alors je vais
passer à la vertical sera peut-être plus
facile pour voir ici vous allez avoir
toute votre console avec vos différents
réglages avec vos différents modes mode
x dynamique Ultra Durable et vous allez
avoir le rock vision qui est activé ici
activer ou désactiver et ensuite vous
cliquez dessus et vous allez voir que ça
s'intéresse donc là il me demande de
venir tourner et en fait vous allez
choisir ce qui va venir s'afficher
derrière là vous voyez par exemple ici
ça va être l'affichage seven qu'on va
venir retrouver ici qui est super joli
donc ça j'aime beaucoup une fois de plus
ça va être vraiment typé le smartphone
ça finit le marquer dans l'univers du
gaming on va avoir également le choix
avec le mode x ici on va voir les
accessoires externes ici Connect ok on
va se retrouver avec la batterie en
charge également donc toutes les
informations de batterie jouer un jeu
Game Start et compagnie et puis pour les
appels entrant donc c'est aussi une
partie notification si vous posez votre
smartphone à l'envers et bien vous allez
avoir toute cette partie là qui va venir
s'afficher s'activer moi je trouve ça
super joli super élégant et une fois de
plus ça porte vraiment quelque chose à
ce smartphone là vous le voyez dans la
version blanc mais il existe également
version noir donc ça va dépendre vous
aurez plus de vous des goûts et des
couleurs de chacun c'est un smartphone
qui fait quand même son petit point 239
g c'est pas le smartphone le plus léger
du marché mais une fois de plus ici il y
a rien de bien surprenant on est en fait
quasiment sur la même mouture que ce
qu'on avait l'année dernière au niveau
du rockfonc 6 à part quelques petits
détails et quelques améliorations mais
en fait l'idée reste quand même
globalement la même alors moi il y a un
point dont je voudrais vraiment qu'on se
parle qui est extrêmement important
c'est toute la partie bien évidemment
gaming gaming mais je vais l'élargir
pour multimédia pourquoi parce que vous
allez voir j'ai d'abord commencé par
vous parler de cet écran cet écran il
est très bien très beau très maîtrisé
c'est une dalle Samsung à molette qui va
avoir un taux de rafraîchissement qui
peut aller jusqu'à 120 Hertz alors
regardez vous allez dans vos paramètres
ici on va venir directement aller dans
affichage alors peut-être truc un petit
bémol je trouve que l'expérience
logiciel elle est un peu tristounette
envoyé parce que ça se détache pas
nécessairement là aujourd'hui beaucoup
de constructeurs font des efforts pour
avoir une expérience qui va être un peu
plus sexy un peu plus jolie un peu plus
de lisibilité alors on a des icônes on a
le titre on a ensuite une information
sur ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver dedans
mais pour autant tout est pareil rien
n'est différencié alors quand on a pris
l'habitude on s'y repère mais dès le
départ je trouve pas ça extrêmement
évident alors pour autant est-ce que
Asus se dit on est dans un truc un petit
peu classique bon ça pourrait quand même
être relativement amélioré vu tout le
travail qu'ils arrivent à apporter aux
différentes expériences globales autour
de ce produit cette expérience là elle
pourra quand même être vraiment optimisé
ça c'est un peu dommage alors on va
aller dans notre affichage et dans notre
affichage on va aller chercher ici le
taux de rafraîchissement le taux de
rafraîchissement ici en automatique et
alors c'est une grosse point fort de ce
smartphone c'est que vous voyez on peut
aller jusqu'à toute rafraîchissement de
165 Hertz c'est quand même énorme donc
ça porte beaucoup de fluidité lorsque
vous allez venir jouer mais pour autant
on n'est pas limité à 165 Hertz vous
pouvez venir le pousser soit en 144 soit
120 soit 90 soit 60 alors 60 c'est
vraiment si vous voulez uniquement
regarder des films et des séries et que
vous voulez prolonger l'autonomie de
votre smartphone sinon sans quoi vous
voulez aller au plus haut vous le mettez
directement en mode 165 Hertz moi ce que
je vous recommande quand même et bien
c'est le laisser en automatique pourquoi
parce qu'il veut dire switcher lui de
façon totalement intelligente et
transparente et comme ça vous prenez
patates et vous posez pas la question
mais voyez ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir tout ce qui est capable de vous
proposer ici comme taux de
rafraîchissement il y en a cinq en
réalité et une fois de plus je trouve ça
cool vous regardez une série 60 hertz
vous jouez un jeu exigeant 165 tout en
sachant ici que vous avez un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 720 Hertz
donc ça c'est vachement bien ça a
vraiment dans l'expérience du gaming
vous appuyez ça répond directement et on
a en plus une latence de 23000 secondes
ce qui sur smartphone globalement est
très correct alors je reviens à cet
écran parce que cet écran il est beau il
est grand il est bien maîtrisé très bien
calibré c'est surtout une très grosse
dalle de 6,78 pouces 111 % des CI P3 en
terme de colorimétrie il est vraiment
bien maîtrisé également alors vous avez
quelques petites options si vous voulez
venir paramétrer un petit peu l'histoire
et elle est un peu plus loin là on est
en optimal on peut se mettre en naturel
il y a une très légère différence vous
rendre compte comme ça vous ça va pas
être évident parce que la vidéo il y a
une colorimétrie qui est appliquée
personnellement je reste en OptImage je
me prends pas la tête sauf qu'il est
vraiment bien fait ici donc pas de souci
on se parle d'une résolution Full HD
plus on se parle d'un écran avec un
deltaE inférieur à 1 et qui surtout a
une nouveauté cette année qui est
intéressante il va venir convertir tout
le contenu qui va être en SDR vers du
HDR donc en gros il va faire le taf tout
seul pour tenir optimiser la qualité de
votre contenu en plus de ça et c'est
aussi une nouveauté il y a encore plus
lumineux que ce qu'on pouvait retrouver
avant avec un pic de luminosité
pour vous dire que si vous allez sur une
expérience gaming à l'extérieur ça va le
faire et en plus de ça et c'est aussi un
gros point fort de ce smartphone c'est
pour toute l'expérience gaming vous
aurez du rétracing alors le rétracing
vous en ai déjà parlé lorsque je vous
parlais du processeur de qualcool ici ce
qu'on va voir à l'intérieur en plus
c'est le stade dragon 8 Jen 2 je vous
avais tout expliqué lorsqu'elle a été
présenté au mois de décembre dernier je
vous avais fait une vidéo complète
dessus donc allez jeter un coup d'oeil
c'est intéressant parce que le rétracing
va vraiment venir apporter notamment au
niveau des ombres au niveau de la
luminosité également et tout ça est du
gras au stade dragon 8 GN2 de Qualcomm
que vous avez à l'intérieur alors
puisqu'on parle de performance et
justement intéressant de venir voir ce
qu'il y a dans le ventre je vous ai dit
on a ce processeur là qui va être 15 à
20% plus performant que ce qu'on avait
sur le stade dragon 8 gène un de l'année
dernière surtout ici on va voir deux
configurations au niveau du stockage
soit 12 Go soit 16 Go de RAM c'est
l'Alpe d'HDR 5x c'est très très bien
actuellement et soit 256 soit 512 giga
de stockage en ufs 4.0 une fois de plus
dans les dernières techno qui iront très
très bien donc ça sera très rapide en
lecture et en écriture et surtout ça
apporte une expérience extrêmement
fluide au niveau de la mémoire donc
c'est vachement bien donc on le comprend
un smartphone qui ne va pas ramer qui va
aller loin qui va être rapide qui va
être performant et qui pour toute
l'expérience de gaming répondra
merveilleusement bien alors il y a un
autre point qui est très fort que j'ai
trouvé déjà très bon chez Asus et que à
chaque fois que j'ai un roquefort dans
les mains je me dis mais c'est pas
possible ce sont les meilleurs dans ce
domaine là et bien c'est l'expérience
audio fait le point qui est super
intéressant ici c'est que vous avez
vraiment de haut-parleurs stéréo ça veut
dire que le haut-parleur vous allez
avoir là est exactement le même
haut-parleur vous allez avoir là donc
vous prenez vraiment le son dans la
gueule à droite comme à gauche de la
même manière il y a une vraie belle
symétrie et ça croyez-moi en expérience
de gaming c'est vraiment génial alors
au-delà d'avoir une belle expérience
audio au-delà de ce côté là et bien on
est sur un smartphone très performant
alors là je vous montre sur un asphalt 9
enfin tourner n'importe quoi c'est un
smartphone qui chauffe pas
particulièrement et si vous avez un
problème de chauffe bien vous avez cette
petite bête en plus vous pouvez venir
mettre très facilement alors là j'ai une
bagnole qui rame complètement dans le
jeu c'est juste la folie folle mais
au-delà de ça on est sur un smartphone
que je trouve extrêmement performant
extrêmement efficace qui est vachement
bien et ce point une fois de plus je
reviens dessus j'insiste un peu mais
c'est super important le fait de voir
c'est haut-parleurs stéréo ça vous
apporte une immersion qui est totalement
dingue et que personnellement j'adore
donc vous voyez pour bien jouer à des
jeux comme asphalt 9 comme tous les jeux
que vous voulez et bien ça vous immerge
dans un son avec un spec qui va être
très large avec des beaux graves avec
des aigus et c'est vrai que par rapport
à l'ensemble des smartphones que je peux
essayer sur le marché celui-là est
vraiment au-dessus mais pas un cran
au-dessus mais peut-être deux trois
grands au-dessus et ça c'est vachement
bien alors là je vous montre bien
évidemment sur un asphalt 9 mais je peux
vous le montrer également sur une vidéo
youtube Regardez je vous montre la
présentation de ma chaîne parce que
là-dessus j'ai les droits vous allez
voir il y a du son c'est beau c'est fort
et c'est vraiment un point extrêmement
important
comme ça mais ça envoie vraiment du bois
et ça c'est vraiment vraiment bien alors
ça sera à vous de vous rendre compte
lorsque vous allez venir le prendre
jouer à l'essayer parce qu'il faut venir
le découvrir je vous assure que cette
expérience multimédia elle est
complètement géniale là-dessus alors il
y a un truc qui a fait également Asus
c'est qu'ils sont dit non sont fous
d'avoir des bords un petit peu grand en
haut et en bas ça c'était déjà le cas
derrière ça continue cette année et bien
ils disent on va planquer notre caméra
de selfie ici mais par contre il y a
rien qui va venir rogner sur le contenu
et l'expérience va être totalement
maximisée avec ni en coche ni bulle ni
caméra ni rien du tout et pour autant
ils sont pas encore allés avec la caméra
sous l'écran peut-être qu'ils estiment
que c'est pas encore suffisamment bon
pour l'instant en tout cas ils ne sont
pas dessus donc vous avez un grand écran
avec fatalement il faut l'accepter des
bordures qui vont être un peu plus
grandes sur le haut et un peu plus
grande sur le bas par rapport à beaucoup
de smartphones mais également aussi sur
le côté où on n'est pas sur un écran
bord à bord le son ici est signé d'Irak
et on voit du bois mais on voit vraiment
du bois et en plus de ça il c'est le
nouveau test cette année par rapport à
l'année dernière et bien on va voir un
volume sonore qui va être augmenté de
50% par rapport au rock fan 6 bien
évidemment de 2022 et avec un son
tridimensionnel plus de spatialisation
ça c'est chouette alors rapidement
puisqu'on est sur l'audio on va y rester
vous avez du Aires I rise audio ou
wireless également vous avez de la PTX
lossless vous avez du stand dragon Sand
et vous avez également de la PTX
adaptatif de qualco donc si vous voulez
l'utiliser à la main pour regarder du
contenu multimédia ou pour vos jeux et
bien l'expérience est top si vous voulez
brancher un casque grâce à la prise jack
et bien l'expérience est top si vous
voulez prendre des écouteurs Bluetooth
l'expérience et top et si vous voulez
prendre une adaptateur en usb-c pour
écouter également de l'audio et bien
l'expérience est top autant vous dire
qu'ici l'expérience audio elle est très
riche alors moi je veux qu'on se parle
effectivement du mode gaming avec
notamment et bien ce mode x alors
regardez je vous remets un petit jeu ici
et on va venir fouiller alors ça c'est
pas si vous connaissez déjà mais c'est
le cas chez Asus pour avoir le Game
génie vous venez ici tac vous balayez et
vous avez votre game génie qui va
arriver en bas alors là vous avez toutes
vos informations notamment au niveau du
taux de rafraîchissement vous choisissez
donc là il est automatique 61-90 Hertz
120 Hertz 144 165 et là vous le passez
en auto alors s'écrit en tout petit
c'est pas évident faut vraiment venir le
voir mais je le vois avec mes yeux on
peut avoir également les informations en
temps réel commutateur réseau blocage de
la navigation les alertes pas d'alerte
verrouillage de la luminosité le mode
arrière plan bref vous avez plein
d'options là qui sont très cool au
niveau des hair trigger on peut venir
les configurer ici boutons à ultrasons
contrôle des mouvements vous allez
pouvoir venir tout paramétrer ici très
facilement on a également la
cartographie des vibrations on va
pouvoir venir choisir ici donc ça une
fois de plus c'est quand même vachement
cool enfin vous avez pas mal d'options
et alors après là je suis en mode
dynamique mais je peux venir changer là
je peux mettre en mode x l'almodic c'est
là où ça va tartiner au maximum je vais
avoir le maximum de performances mais
l'autonomie va venir descendre
fatalement donc là vous le voyez ça
c'est dynamique ça c'est Ultra Durable
là je vais venir ralentir un peu les
performances mais gagner en autonomie et
après je peux venir choisir directement
ce que je veux en faire et venir le
customiser personnellement je vais
mettre sur dynamique pour l'instant ça
m'ira bien et moi ce que je vous
recommande quand même si vous utilisez
le mode X et bien c'est de venir avoir
votre aeroactive couleur qui vient se
brancher très facilement que vous venez
prendre vous venez clipser derrière la
TAG vous voyez vous le mettez juste
derrière ensuite ça redescend ici ça
vient se positionner ça va permettre
d'avoir une vraie belle ventilation
lorsque vous allez venir jouer à des
jeux ça va évacuer l'air vous allez
avoir votre
pas trop éclairage qui va apporter un
côté expérience un peu plus sexy au
niveau de votre smartphone vos boutons
ici vous allez pouvoir regarder en plus
ici venir l'ouvrir tac vous le prenez et
vous le pouvez le poser sur une table
comme ça facilement alors après ça vous
permet de venir regarder du contenu donc
si vous voulez le refroidir en même
temps vous mettre un petit film vous
posez dans un train et compagnie et bien
vous le posez à plat comme ça ça fait le
taf c'est quand même très cool et après
il y a le petit bouton ici qui vous sert
à venir allumer et éteindre votre
Smartphone vous voyez c'est un petit
commutateur Renault et vous appuyez sur
le bouton ici ça vous le lève vous avez
qu'à le déclipser vous le prenez vous
l'enlevez vous êtes partis ça c'est bien
et le résultat est sans appel vous
pouvez regarder sur en tout ou avec un
score de 1 million 343 757 et sur le
classement ça vient de mettre en
première position ce qui est juste
énorme devant le Red Magic 8 Pro plus
devant le vivo X90 pro plus devant le
Xiaomi 13 pro bref aujourd'hui il a la
tête du classement donc c'est sans appel
aujourd'hui en tout cas le smartphone le
plus puissant qu'on peut retrouver ici
sur Android donc on voit qu'on a un
smartphone qui est extrêmement
performant qui est très bon pour le
multimédia qui est très bon pour le
gaming qui va bien qu'il y a un moment
ne change pas énormément lorsque vous le
tenez à la main mais bon sur la pression
un petit peu exigeante il peut venir
chauffer un peu plus et on sait que la
chauffe c'est l'ennemi de la performance
donc si vous mettez le mode X vous
mettez la Hero actif couleur comme ça il
y aura absolument aucun problème alors
l'autre point qui est intéressant c'est
l'autonomie ici vous avez une très
grosse batterie de 6000 milliards avec
de la recharge rapide avec le bloc de
charge intégré ça c'est très bien ici
Asus ça fait le choix de ne pas mettre
de charge sans fil c'était déjà pas le
cas avant c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
je pense que il dit ça sert à rien ou
alors ils ont pas la place ou alors ils
veulent pas augmenter les coûts alors
j'en sais rien en tout cas il y a pas de
recharge sans fil ici mais vous avez un
bloc de charge de 65 watts donc c'est
globalement assez rapide et puis surtout
vous savez Asus ils aiment bien
optimiser un peu les choses ils aiment
bien aller le plus loin possible ils ont
fait un truc qui est vachement bien
fichu ici c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
venir régler vos modes au niveau de la
consommation au niveau de votre batterie
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment vous pouvez
jouer sur votre blog de charge branché
mais ne pas venir recharger la batterie
de votre smartphone pour éviter de lui
mettre des grands cycles en permanence
et de venir l'user prématurément donc
vous pouvez venir faire un bypass de
votre charge bien que vous ayez votre
smartphone qui soit branché sur le
chargeur donc ça c'est quand même cool
c'est pas nouveau c'est déjà là avant
mais une fois de plus c'est bien donc il
faut le dire et il y a eu si une
optimisation une amélioration du système
de refroidissement donc ça smartphone
qui va être encore mieux refroidi par
rapport parce qu'on avait avant autre
point qui est important ici vous avez
deux ans de mise à jour Android on
tourne sur un Android 13 vous aurez donc
Android 14 Android 15 sans problème et 4
ans de mise à jour de sécurité donc si
vous achetez votre Smartphone vous êtes
sûr qu'en termes de sécurité vous êtes
tranquille vous êtes pénal pendant au
moins 4 ans et aussi une des
spécificités de ce smartphone et bien
c'est Armory create qui est l'expérience
gaming de Asus Rogue ici et on le
retrouve bien évidemment sous forme
d'application parce qu'on peut l'avoir
effectivement lorsqu'on joue dans le
game Jenny mais ici on le retrouve en
grand ensemble c'est bien c'est beau
c'est clair avec toutes les informations
alors vous avez la liste de vos jeux
vous pouvez en trouver d'autres
également et vous avez toutes les
informations sur votre smartphone là
j'ai un CPU à 31 degrés je pars j'ai pu
à 31 degrés j'ai une température de
système à 27 degrés je vais avoir ma
fréquence également mon stockage mon
temps restant au niveau de mon autonomie
ça c'est plutôt pas mal ma mémoire je
suis sur 16 Go ici voyez je vois la
mémoire qui est occupé je vois le
stockage qui occupé enfin bref c'est
vraiment très très complet et une fois
de plus je peux venir arbitrer comment
est-ce que je veux que ce smartphone
soit mode dynamique par exemple vous
voyez c'est un mode qui est très
équilibré avec l'amélioration du réseau
l'endurance de la batterie la ré tactile
la performance du système et le taux de
rafraîchissement et si je passe en mode
X et bien forcément je vais venir
pousser le côté taux de rafraîchissement
côté performance système côté
amélioration du réseau mais par contre
l'endurance de la batterie elle va en
prendre un petit coup dans la tête et
les réactivité tactile elle sera aussi
très très bonne vous voyez une
différence ça vient vraiment pousser
d'un côté et on voit que le côté
batterie vient un peu diminué tandis que
si je vais sur le Ultra Durable et bien
ça va venir rapprocher côté de la
batterie et tout le reste va vraiment
drastiquement diminuer donc
l'amélioration du réseau le taux de
rafraîchissement et la performance du
système va venir un peu plus bas ça sera
un peu moins bon donc vous voyez une
vraie différence entre l'ultra durable
et le mode x c'est un peu l'opposé ça va
donc dépendre des besoins que vous aurez
un instant T et une fois de plus pour
tous les usage un peu classique un peu
standard vous avez pas besoin de le
pousser à fond et bien vous mettez en
mode dynamique ça ira très très bien le
rock vision dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure l'aéroactive couleur qu'on va
pouvoir venir brancher ici directement
sur lequel on aura des informations qui
est aussi très très cool et qui prend
aussi en charge la heroactive couleur
side donc de la génération antérieure il
faut savoir que si vous avez un iPhone 6
vous ne pouvez pas venir câbler un aéro
actif couleur 7 ça ne marchera pas et
puis le génie du jeu les données du jeu
en premier bref pas mal le petit
paramètre au niveau du génie du jeu vos
préférences et vos réglages au niveau
des air trigger et puis la petite
mission de déballage dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure que on vient
retrouver ici mission terminée on peut
la refaire à nouveau ensuite là vous
êtes connecté directement avec votre
compte Asus avec toutes vos informations
réseaux social Asus et compagnie gaming
ok wind des jeux disponibles qu'on peut
venir télécharger votre compte que vous
trouvez directement là le gaming c'est
bien l'expérience multimédia et les tops
c'est un super smartphone qui va vite
qui va bien qui ne chauffe pas on a des
accessoires il y a des trucs très cool
allez voir sur le site d'Asus il y a
plein d'accessoires c'est très bien mais
la partie photo ça a toujours été un peu
le parent pauvre des rock Phone et là
vous voyez vous avez trois capteurs
alors trois capteurs regardons ce qu'on
a sous le capot on va avoir un premier
grand angle de 50 mégapixels c'est la
fameuse caméra de Sony c'est l'immx 766
c'est exactement la même caméra qu'on
avait dans le rock on 6 l'année dernière
vous avez ensuite un ultra grand angle
de 13 mégapixels et vous avez également
de la macro en 13 mégapixels sans
oublier votre petit flashlight qui situe
juste ici alors la nouveauté c'est qu'on
peut aussi avoir du rose ok pourquoi pas
sans oublier une caméra de selfie qui
est planqué ici de 32 mégapixels il faut
savoir que la caméra de selfie du
rockfonc 6 était une caméra de 12
mégapixels donc vous voyez ils ont
rajouté un peu de mégapixel mais on va
regarder tout de suite si c'est bien
meilleur ou si globalement c'est un peu
la même chose regardez les photos là on
a une photo qui est prise sur le grand
angle de 50 mégapixels et je la trouve
moins pire que ce que j'avais les années
précédentes je trouve même plutôt pas
mal alors après il faut savoir qu'ici
j'ai pas de stabilisation optique ça
risque de bouger un peu et surtout avec
moi je peux vous assurer quand je prends
des photos comme ça ça bouge énormément
pour autant je trouve ça pas mal
pourquoi
parce global je le trouve jolie je
trouve satisfaisant entre d'un côté mes
nuages qui vont bien ressortir avec ma
façade qui ressort bien avec mon herbe
verte avec le côté un peu plus dans la
pénombre sur le côté qui ressort bien et
tout ça c'est dû à quoi c'est dû en fait
au stade dragon 8 gène 2 et son module
de traitement d'image qui va être
meilleur son icep qui va être meilleur
que ce qu'on avait avant et pour moi ça
a été vraiment significativement à
améliorer la qualité des photos qu'on
retrouve ici et puis aussi le fait qu'on
est la Sony mx766 qui va quand même
jouer là dedans mais il est sûr que de
toute façon le rock phone c'est pas le
photophone par excellence c'est pas le
super smartphone pour faire des photos
mais là globalement ça sort pas mal
alors c'est à côté un peu trop flatteur
un peu sur saturé mais je trouve que la
photo est quand même vraiment pas mal
fichue alors l'ultra grand-angle on voit
qu'il y a une différence de colorimétrie
et tout de suite on perd vachement en
piqué on est sur un ultra grand-angle
c'est pas forcément surprenant et c'est
pas ce qu'il a mis le plus c'est pas fou
fou mais ça fait le taf on peut venir
zoomer un peu mais après c'est
uniquement du zoom numérique ici c'est à
dire x 2 x 4 après on peut jusqu'à x 8
ça va pas très loin et vous allez voir
que ça va rapidement se dégrader on voit
qu'il y a effectivement un côté un peu
plus poussif du point de vue
algorithmique on le voit au niveau des
branches ici c'est pas très naturel
c'est pas très très beau et voyez plus
on zoom puis ça se dégrade et c'est pas
surprenant ici une fois de plus ici une
photo prise avec ce grand angle qui
quand même plutôt pas mal franchement je
suis assis surpris parce que je connais
les Rolls une fois de plus j'ai jamais
trouvé ça extraordinaire là c'est pas
mal fichu l'ultra grand-angle et pas
dégueu plus saturé pour le coup ici que
le grand-angle et puis bon après on
zoome mais non en fait on va pas zoomer
c'est pas terrible le grand-angle qui
est pas mal
ultra grand-angle bon voilà et on évite
de venir zoomer je monte sur des petites
fleurs aussi alors il y a des petits
trucs à venir regarder quand même ici
c'est que on voit qu'il y a quand même
quelques défauts qui viennent se situer
au niveau des hautes lumières il va
avoir un petit peu de mal on le voit ici
sur toutes les fleurs qui sont blanches
voyez elles sont un poil cramé par
endroits c'est un peu la limite de ce
qu'on va pouvoir venir retrouver alors
même si c'est pas un grand module photo
ça reste quand même très correct et
alors c'est vrai qu'on va se dire mais
plus de 1000 balles dans un smartphone
mais une fois de plus un smartphone
vraiment orienté gaming avec toute
l'expérience gaming donc c'est pas
surprenant que l'expérience soit diminué
d'un point de vue traitement photo le
mode macro bon voilà ces photos sont pas
dégueu dégueu je trouve pas ça je
suis pas très très fan c'est pas évident
de faire plus de venir trouver la bonne
distance mais là vous voyez c'est pas
trop mauvais au centre je vais vous en
montrer une autre celle-là je trouve
sympa parce que on voit bien les petits
poils au niveau de la c'est bien éclairé
alors attention les hautes lumières et
bien il va avoir un petit peu plus de
mal ici à venir les traiter c'est pas
foufou globalement je pense que ça
servira à rien mais bon dans l'idée
pourquoi pas et une fois de plus de ces
petits poils là qui ressortent donc la
définition est pas dégueu bon voilà je
suis pas convaincu qu'on en fasse
grand-chose mais en tout cas c'est pas
mauvais la caméra de selfie est pas
mauvaise non plus vous voyez je suis
plutôt assez content de ce que je vois
au niveau photo ça c'est quand même
vraiment amélioré merci au stade dragon
vite Gen2 combien trouver ici des pots
qui sont pas lissés on retrouve une
teinte de peau qui est naturel une expo
qui est pas mauvaise là avec le soleil
de face mais un peu dans l'eau qui
ressort c'est pas mauvais là un peu sur
le contre-jour bon il le sont des choses
très cohérentes et je trouve ça pas mal
alors c'est un smartphone qui n'a pas de
certification
IP68 il faudra se contenter de
certification IP54 c'est-à-dire
résistant aux éclaboussures donc s'il
rencontre un peu de flotte et un peu de
pluie ça va bien se passer on a par
contre du wifi 7 ça c'est très bien
alors le wifi ça tu es pas encore
déployé on en est encore en wifi 6 Wi-Fi
6e le wifi 7 arrivera à l'horizon 2024
mais une fois de plus comme c'est un
smartphone si vous l'achetez vous allez
garder dans le temps et bien il est déjà
prêt pour le wifi 7 alors ça c'est bien
mais quand les petits au niveau du taré
vous me direz alors regardez vous avez
ici plusieurs configuration vous avez
soit 12 giga de ram 256 giga de stockage
et on est à 1029 euros si vous voulez
monter c'est la version que j'ai ici 16
512 ça coûte
1199 euros et alors après il y a aussi
le roquefort ultimate qui globalement
change pas grand chose vous allez avoir
l'airole couleur qui est inclus avec
vous allez pas avoir en plus mais si
vous l'acheter là jusqu'au 30 avril sur
l'offre de lancement et bien vous
l'aurez qui est offert sur le refunset
donc pas besoin forcément de l'avoir il
sera uniquement en blanc vous allez
avoir un écran OLED à l'arrière
uniquement mais il y a globalement pas
d'autres différences et c'est
sensiblement le même smartphone et lui
en version 16 + 512 il coûtera
1429 euros donc pour moi le vrai bon
plan ici c'est le rock Phone 7 que vous
allez pouvoir acheter avec 12 ou 16 Go
de RAM 12 et 1 globalement quand même
très bien on va pas se mentir et si vous
le prenez pendant l'offre de lancement
et bien vous aurez votre aéro actif
couleur qui est quand même un accessoire
à indispensable et qui est quand même
super important ici déjà pour maximiser
l'expérience de jeu et en plus pour
venir le refroidir et en plus ça vous
fait un petit stand si vous voulez
regarder des films et des séries donc ça
c'est quand même plutôt bien donc si ce
smartphone vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description et puis je
compte sur vous pour me dire ce que vous
en pensez comment vous le trouvez sur
offenset c'est une très belle évolution
du rock fan 6 avec plus de performances
avec des technologies de RAM et de
stockage qui sont dernière génération
donc ils vont aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est sensiblement la même chose au
niveau de la photo l'écran reste
toujours très beau très bien maîtrisé il
y a pas de grande surprise ici vous avez
des thèmes préinstallés qui sont très
mignons et qui ont très bien mais bon
voilà c'est pas ça qui va bien changer
la face du monde non plus il y a
quelques petites nouveautés qui sont
ajoutées par ci par-là qui viennent de
rendre un peu plus savoureux mais dans
l'ensemble c'est une belle évolution du
rock fan 6 qui reste ici malgré tout
très chouette et très bien réussi et qui
pour moi et aujourd'hui le meilleur
smartphone de gaming sur le marché et le
meilleur smartphone pour avoir une très
belle expérience multimédia notamment
grâce à l'expérience audio donc
dites-moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'il vous plaît vous intéresse
oui non pas comment est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu des rock Phone et est-ce que de
rockfon 7 pourrait vous botter marquez
moi ça en bas dans les commentaires et
on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler de Take Asus vous
allez voir il y a des choses qui
arrivent très alléchantes mais pas que
je vous embrasse à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]